C’est étonnant, ce matin
ces petites fleurs blanches sont fermées,
ce sont des oxalis, alors qu’hier en milieu d’après-midi,
elles étaient complètement ouvertes.
Et celle-ci aussi.
Si, si, la petite caméra l’a filmée.
Comme si elles avaient fermé les yeux pendant la nuit.
Peut-être qu’elles dorment encore ! Chut…
Ce phénomène s’appelle la « nyctinastie ».
Oh là ! Il y a des racines grecques là-dessous !
Normal !
On parle de plantes.
Le grec permet de décrire
précisément le phénomène
et en plus, c’est un langage international
pour les botanistes.
Je vous éclaire !
Ça va ?
Vous êtes toujours là ?
"Nyc" de "nyx",
qui veut dire nuit.
Et Nastie…
pour "mouvement".
On parle aussi de
position de sommeil,
comme si la plante avait besoin
de fermer les paupières pour s’endormir.
*Bâillement.
C’est pas la seule…
Mais comment ce mouvement
est-il possible,
alors que la plante ne possède
ni muscle ni système nerveux ?
Pour comprendre, il faut observer un pétale de très près. Encore plus près que ne le font les insectes…
Comme ça,
ça va ?
Dans l’épaisseur, il est constitué
d’un empilement de cellules.
Chaque cellule se présente
sous la forme d’une petite brique
à l’intérieur de laquelle se trouve un sac
appelé "vacuole", qui contient de l’eau.
Il y a aussi des sels minéraux,
du calcium notamment.
Là, c’est le noyau de la cellule qui renferme
le matériel génétique de la plante.
Quand la nuit tombe, la baisse de luminosité entraîne une modification de la concentration en calcium.
Il y en a davantage dans les cellules
qui se trouvent sous le pétale.
Pour rétablir l’équilibre, ces cellules se gorgent d’eau, tandis que celles du dessus se vident et se contractent.
Ça pousse d’un côté, ça tracte de l’autre…
Les pétales se referment.
On peut illustrer le phénomène avec un ballon de baudruche et une feuille de papier très léger.
Le ballon de baudruche représente
les cellules qui se trouvent sous le pétale.
En gonflant, les cellules prennent du volume
et le pétale se redresse. Comme ceci !
Alors ça,
je ne m’y attendais pas.
Ajoutez à cela la contraction des cellules
qui se trouvent au-dessus et qui exercent une traction
et le pétale se redresse
d’autant plus facilement. Je recommence !
Voilà ! Le pétale qui était couché
s’est redressé.
Dans mon jardin, le phénomène dure
environ dix minutes et c’est très beau.
Au petit matin,
c’est l’inverse.
Les cellules qui se trouvent au-dessous se vident et se contractent. Celles situées au-dessus se gorgent d’eau.
Ça pousse au-dessus, ça tracte en-dessous
et la fleur s’ouvre. Et c’est aussi très beau.
Mais attention ! Les plantes
ne font pas cela pour attirer notre regard.
La fleur héberge
les organes sexuels de la plante.
Les étamines, qui portent à leur extrémité des petits sacs de pollen, les cellules reproductrices mâles de la plante
et le pistil, qui contient à sa base des ovules,
les cellules reproductrices femelles.
Ces plantes ont besoin des insectes pollinisateurs
pour se reproduire. Les abeilles par exemple.
Le jour, elles vont de fleur en fleur
pour faire le plein de nectar et de pollen.
En passant d’une fleur à l’autre, elles transportent
le pollen de l’une sur le pistil de l’autre
et participent ainsi activement
à la reproduction des plantes.
La nuit, quand les insectes se reposent,
la fleur se referme
pour protéger ses organes reproducteurs
du froid et de l’humidité.
Et faire en sorte qu’au petit matin, les insectes
aient de quoi se mettre sous la dent et polliniser.
Chaque plante a son propre rythme.
Elles se sont adaptées au fil de l’évolution
à l’activité de leurs pollinisateurs.
Il existe des plantes, par exemple,
dont la pollinisation dépend d'animaux nocturnes.
C’est le cas de certains ananas sauvages qui sont essentiellement pollinisés par des chauves-souris.
Leurs fleurs s’ouvrent donc la nuit
et se referment le jour !
Carl Von Linné,
le célèbre botaniste suédois du XVIIIe siècle.
Il est l’auteur de la première
classification des plantes
Depuis, elle a bien sur été revue et corrigée
mais avant c’était vraiment la jungle.
Carl Von Linné a même
réalisé une horloge florale.
Lorsqu’il était en Guyane, il était capable de deviner l’heure rien qu’en observant l’ouverture des fleurs.
Quand cette petite fleur jaune s’ouvre :
une Urticularia, il est aux alentours de 7 heures.
Quand la Nymphoïde indica - ou faux nénuphar - s’épanouit, il est 8 heures.
À 9 heures, c’est l’Ilysanthe qui ouvre les volets
et à 10 : Cabomba aquatica.
Oh ! Elle commence à se fermer !
Je vais être en retard… il faut vraiment que j’y aille !
À très bientôt…
Avec la petite caméra, nous aussi,
nous allons prendre un peu de vacances.
Du coup, jusqu'à la rentrée, nous nous ne retrouverons plus qu'une fois tous les 15 jours.
Ce n'est pas tout. La prochaine fois, le 25 juillet donc,
la vidéo sera un peu différente des précédentes.
En seulement 3 mois, vous avez
franchi le cap des 500 000 abonnés !
C’est énorme…
Merci à toutes et à tous.
Pour fêter cela, je prépare une vidéo FAQ
pour répondre à toutes vos questions
sur les capsules, les coulisses des tournages,
les prochains "Le Monde de Jamy" également.
Posez-les en commentaire de cette vidéo
en commençant par « Dis Jamy...»
ou sur Twitter
en commençant par #DisJamy.
Je suis impatient de vous lire
et de vous répondre !
À très bientôt et passez
d'excellentes vacances !